[Musique]
non c'était la première soirée
d'exposition du prix célimène à la villa
du département
une seizième édition toujours réservé
aux femmes artistes amateurs qui ont
exposé des oeuvres originales des
sculptures des peintures ou des
photographies un concours artistique qui
valorise les talents de la réunion au
féminin
[Musique]
parmi les 145 oeuvres en lice trois ont
été primés la lauréate du concours et
billing qui remporte le premier prix en
catégorie peinture pour son oeuvre
je t'aime 1000 quand j'ai eu un petit
garçon je le voyais comme un ange
parce que c'était mon premier enfant je
ne savais pas d'où il venait peut-être
du paradis ou d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
mais je savais qu'il venait d'un endroit
pur il sourit beaucoup et quand il le
fait c'est comme s'il y avait plein de
fleurs pour la troisième année
consécutive le département récompense
également les jeunes talents avec le
prix célimène junior et c'est le collège
jean le toullec au port qui remporte le
premier prix pour son oeuvre
la célimène face seul le public pourra
découvrir toutes ces heures du 9 au 27
mars
en parcourant l'exposition dans les
salons de la villa du département
[Musique]